joining me now is Republican Ohio
Governor Mike DeWine governor good to
see I'm sure you're sympathetic with the
problems thank you of the New York
government right now trying to deal with
its first death our our governor's
working together sharing information
trying to share plans that they have
particularly in light of the the
availability now that we will see coming
this week of those tests well no
absolutely we are sharing information
and we're working also closely with the
Trump administration in fact we got a
waiver yesterday we're very happy about
in regard to we closed our schools as
you reported now the concern is how do
you get food out to kids they gave us a
specific waiver that allows us to
package this food and actually take it
out it's going to be up to the local
school district how to do it but they
were very fast within 24 hours and less
than that got that waiver we also got
supplies a notification of supplies
coming in so look everybody's in this
together we're sharing information with
the federal government they're sharing
with us we're sharing with with our
fellow governor's so you know we're all
in this we all got the same that same
challenge we know we do it's like it's
like after 9/11 I mean we do we got it
we got to come together in the similar
way I'm sorry but time is short I just
have to ask you one thing about testing
that's going to be great is we will get
some some clear numbers about how many
people have been infected your
Department of Health had a me act and
said this week that in fact a hundred
thousand people have are carrying the
virus in the state of Ohio that's an
extraordinarily high figure do you stand
by her figure we what what she said is
that you some modeling would show at
this point that that's what we have we
know we have wide spread community
spread so we got a lot of people in Ohio
who have that and that's the message and
that's why we shut the schools last
night I shut the casinos Recinos in Ohio
we're talking to people in regard to day
care and if you can take your child out
of daycare do it we're telling the
daycare people let's you know if there's
ways to set segments different groups of
kids in daycare that's that's certainly
the way to do it but you mentioned
earlier about
we've been voting in Ohio since February
19th we continued to vote
polls are open for anybody watching from
Ohio polls are open today they're open
Sunday they're open Monday and of course
Tuesday is 13 hours 6:30 in the morning
at 7:30 at night so they're open and
you're right we did move some polling
places we move them out of nursing-homes
that made no sense and also the schools
were closed so that we're not mixing on
Tuesday we're not mixing people with the
kids and vice-versa so we're taking some
pretty dramatic action well and and and
let's hope that the testing the the new
availability of testing shows that those
numbers are not as high because if it is
a hundred thousand people in Ohio with
just 11 million people that would that
would mean the numbers for the United
States as a whole would be
extraordinarily high so again we have to
what we'll hear once the tests come out
quickly go ahead sir no I just want to
say I think the key here is though
experts who have looked at this and
modeled this that without intervention
without us doing those things we would
expect in this country to have 40 to 70
percent of our population eventually get
this so we're trying to take those
numbers down and that's that's why we're
talking about big numbers because that's
what unfortunately we're looking at well
governor we wish you the very best you
and the people of Ohio very very near
and dear to our hearts and and we're
praying for you thank you very much
governor appreciate you thank you very
much I appreciate it